former House Oversight Committee
Chairman and Fox News contributor trey
Gowdy and what the vice-president knew
if anything about the insurance policy
that we've talked so much about Trey
good to have you here tonight thanks for
being here so I thought we would start
by taking a look at this tweet by
President Trump he says if I were a
senator or congressman the first person
that I would call to testify about the
biggest political crime and scandal in
the history of the USA by far is former
President Obama he knew everything the
president writes in caps do it at
Lindsey Graham South Carolina just do it
no more mr. nice guy
no more talk and here is the response by
Senator Lindsey Graham to that tweet
let's watch that no presence above the
law
but we do have separations of powers and
I think could be a bad precedent to
compel a former president to come before
the Congress that would open up a can of
worms and I for a variety of reasons I
don't think that's a good idea
so who do you agree with here
trey well let me say this I understand
fully what the president is frustrated I
mean it his first term in office has
been under a manufacturer clout by his
opponents so I understand his
frustration I'll tell you what my advice
mother advice to Republicans would be
what five months away from the general
election the house is up and a third of
the Senate's up let's don't fight
publicly let's don't have these
internecine battles five months before
the general election this is what I
think you should do first of all get all
the documents get all the evidence
Martha you reference Susan Rice there's
a part of that email that no one's ever
read because it's still classified
how about the Comey emails how about any
text with with Annie mccabe and Jim
Comey so there are a lot of documents
that need to be declassified and I if I
call President Obama he would be the
last witness because I don't like
surprises I mean this is not a mystery
this is not entertainment we are trying
to persuade and communicate you
ready know what Samantha power and Susan
Rice and McCabe and Co me and Brennan
and clapper you already know what role
they played so lay that out for the jury
and then I would call Biden before I
called President Obama because remember
a president Trump was impeached for
trying to investigate his political
enemies well maybe that's what Biden did
I mean I don't know it but if it's good
for president Trump wouldn't be good for
Biden it wouldn't you want to know that
here's the question you know with regard
to the names on this unmasking list it's
my understanding that it may or may not
mean much that some of those names are
there because someone else asked them to
you know put their name on the unmasking
request and that perhaps you know the
person who was behind most of the desire
to unmask those it doesn't have their
name on that list at all does that add
up to you do you agree with that it does
not I may not heard that from Samantha
power I mean the number of unmasking she
requested what was so far outside the
realm and then she said she didn't know
about most of them but but but that's a
problem too isn't it if you give the
power to someone to unmask and they're
delegating that power took to a clerk or
a subordinate this is the question for
Joe Biden we know you asked - unmai
unmasked Michael Flynn's name we know
that how many other unmasking requested
you may I mean were you a serial
unmasked her while you were the vice
president or was this the only one I
can't answer that question but I think
it's really relevant
you know I mean let me let me ask you
this because you know in terms of this
battle over whether or not this should
go so far up in terms of investigation
into Joe Biden or President Obama
there's no indication that the
Department of Justice or that John
Durham are considering either one of
those two people that I just named in
their investigation and we know that
because of something that the Attorney
General said in an interview with Hugh
Hewitt just a short while just a short
while back at the end of April watch
this
as far as I'm aware none of me the key
people that these actions are being with
you'd at this point thank you I'm a
running for president what do you think
about that
follow the evidence I may know wherever
yep I mean that's why you put a career
prosecutor this apolitical like John
Durham and in that position wherever the
evidence takes I mean if Joe Biden
didn't make the unmasking request and
wasn't involved in any of the Flynn
decisions then so be it
but someone needs to tell us that he's
certainly not immune from investigation
what I took that to mean is there's no
evidentiary support for it yet but I
don't think terms through either you
won't know until you talk to the
witnesses I mean that's kind of my point
with the FBI I mean you don't know
who'll eat until you ask them all right
so you know obviously Lindsey Graham's
gonna get some pushback from you know
the president's supporters on this
because a lot of people look at these
situations from the beginning and say no
one has actually been held accountable
it's an enormous source of frustration
for a lot of the president's supporters
in this country and you know they've
also pushed back on on you about that
with not subpoenaing some of your
colleagues have asked why you didn't
subpoena more actively when you had the
chance to do so do you have any regrets
about that well look Martha I was part
of investigations from the moment I got
to Congress I didn't volunteer for him I
was drafted for most of them so you and
I could have an entire hour all the
mistakes I made I was not the chairman
of House Intelligence Committee Devin
unas was and he did a phenomenal job Bob
Goodlatte was the chairman of the
Judiciary Committee and when it kicked
up to him I think he did a phenomenal
job
so whoever thinks that I failed to issue
subpoenas either doesn't understand the
way Congress works or just wants to do a
drive-by shooting and I'm not running
again so I don't know what threat I pose
to them but but but there are plenty of
things to criticize but you just don't
pick the wrong one one of the things
that I remember you saying you know
Congress doesn't have the power to
prosecute so you know and that's one of
the issues in terms of the role of
Congress but one other question for you
because I heard you talk about this in
the back-and-forth you talked about
going to the FBI and getting you know
assurances about certain things with
regard to the Russian investigation and
then learning a lot more in in documents
that you were able to see at the
Department of Justice that changed your
mind about what you had heard originally
in that
and I thought that that was interesting
and it makes me wonder when you look
back at that discussion with Christopher
Rea do you think that he that he was
misleading to you well there's no
question what Devin and I were told in
the briefings did not match up with the
documents so the mistake I made which I
will confess to is believing the word of
DOJ and FBI officials that came after
Trump was elected let's be really clear
about that I wasn't in the room of Jim
Comey and Peter struck I was in the room
with people that came after President
Trump I should have gotten the documents
first I'm glad I got him three weeks
later
yeah I'm not I'm not I'm not asking
about you know your actions I'm really
asking about Christopher Rea here
because you know if he was not
forthcoming and that then the documents
revealed something separate do you think
that he's the person to be running the
FBI well I did not pick him I will tell
you this the FBI told us that nothing
happened before a certain date the Trump
campaign was not the target Donald Trump
was not the target you go look at that
origination initiation report from Peter
striking that mentions Trump campaign
that's when my mind switched when I when
I looked at the documents it did not
match you up with the briefing that
Devin and Paul and I received so as for
Chris right I always notice the
president picked him yes ma'am yeah
thank you so much trey gowdy always good
ma'am thank you